we're in the control center we're about
to go down to one of the one of the
caverns so this side uh over here the is
the particulars of the different aspects
of the detectors there are about four
detectors make up the hole detector each
one has got different parts
and on this side is the main control
room
where they look after the safety of the
detector and the running of it
so this is a great idea these are the
people that work on cms and there's
portraits of them all
and then if you stand back you can see
it's in black and white and the
the white bit make out the word c
m
s the letters cms and they're all the
women
how often do you say that
where the detector is and just behind
this wall here
apparently you just go
a little warren's nest but you is the
lhc itself the the actual ring where the
particles come round and then come into
the detector
but it looks like uh there's we haven't
got access yet we're in
kevin
so be careful of the step
wow
this is it it's the detector we're here
and you've got the beam comes in
and it goes into this monster it's noisy
it's it's like if you've been on a on a
ship on um
you know across across the english
channel or something and you're on
you're on the the hum of the engines
constantly that's what you can hear and
you
and you can just see people i mean you
just get an idea of the size of it there
are two people here
and i don't this
it's uh about 20 about 15 meters
tall
and 15 meters across
and it's something like
26 meters long it's huge
well i've calmed down a bit now brady
and i think i can begin to talk about it
um
let's perhaps begin uh with the with the
pipe because it's it's amazing there are
these two people that we can just see
across here and they're doing some work
on the detector
but if you look by the head of one of
them you can see what looks like a
goldish pipe
look how small it is
that's the lhc pipe that's where the
protons are coming in
at the
about
just within three meters per second of
the speed of light they're coming in
they're coming into the detector here
and in the center of this detector which
is about 21 meters long so about 10
meters in here they're colliding with
another beam of particles which have
been coming the other way or one thing
that i was just being told about the
beam which i hadn't thought about at all
was the beam in the center is made of a
different material that the pipe is made
of beryllium
and you should it's in order to make
sure that when the particles that are
created from the collision of the
protons come out they don't just hit a
big steel beam pipe and just bounce off
in all directions they can get out
and so they've had it's the most
sensitive part in many ways is the
central beam pipe of the lhc which is in
the in the center of the of the detector
here when they collide it's really
important that they remain within the
seal pipe that they're in a vacuum which
is a ten times better than the uh vacuum
in the on the moon i mean the atmosphere
is so
so small there's so few particles in the
pipe that anything that's created
doesn't interact with anything else it
can it can move out
so you've got this central bit of the
detector which is the smallest bit but
is in in fact the most sensitive because
there they've got they've got pixels
lots of little pixels something like 80
million per square meter
80 million per square meter they have to
be able to monitor the
direction and the momentum of the
particles that are coming out so that
they can work out where exactly the
collision took place
and so they've got this very sensitive
stuff made of semiconductors silicon so
that what any particles that comes out
barely affects it
you get currents flowing through the
silicon and that allows you then to read
off where the particles have come from
the particles aren't affected they then
move out to a second set of detectors
called the calorimeters and the
calorimeters actually stop the particles
nearly all of them they absorb the
energy of the particles you've got the
electromagnetic calorimeters which will
stop the charged particles like like um
photons that are produced well they're
not charged but they'll be stopped by
the electromagnetic calorimeter anything
that
interacts electromagnetically will be
stopped by those if you go further out
you have the hydronic
calorimeters and they stop things that
are neutral and and undergo the strong
interaction like the like the neutrons
any neutrons that are produced get
stopped by them
and then on the outside the bulk of the
detector here is actually for stopping
the muons these elementary particles
which are
like electrons but 200 times heavier
and they're so important because if you
find a muon it tells you that something
really high energy has happened they're
very difficult to create and so you if
if if a new one's detected and and
they're very difficult to detect they
just shoot through all the other things
we've been describing if you get the
muon out in these outer
uh rings and in fact the there's a set
of muon detectors these silvery looking
uh detectors here uh on the end cap and
they're surrounding the whole the whole
detector
they're there to absorb the muons that
come through
and then
inside all of this
as some huge magnet magnets solenoid
magnets which produce magnetic fields of
around 4 tesla and that's the way you
detect things like charged particles one
of the ways that you know from school a
charged particle going through a
magnetic field will get bent by the
magnetic field
and because this is so compact so dense
they're able to do it so that the muons
will as they come
that they're created in the center of
the detector as they come out they'll
get bent in one direction they'll then
leave the solenoid
and because they're leaving the solenoid
the direction of the magnetic field
changes so they're bent say this way and
then they get bent that way so there's a
unique signature of a muon like a wave
getting bent one way than the other
and by detecting them
that's the first ex first piece of
evidence that they have
that there's some high energy physics
going on some new physics and they use
that to actually determine which events
they're going to keep there is something
like
800 million collisions a second going on
in there
so they can't keep all the data from 800
million collisions
so what they do they have to have a
trigger system a way in which they can
say well out of those 800 million how
many do we are we interested in and one
of the first the level one trigger is to
look for the muons being detected within
microseconds they track back to the
center of the detector
and look for what else has been present
there and they make a decision
based on that or whether to keep the
event or let it go and they go down from
600 million a second they actually store
between 100 and 200 events a second so
that they can analyze them later on i
think in the course of a year if they
start every event
the cds would take would go to the moon
and back twice that would be the amount
of data they could store and we can't
so you need this big detector basically
even though you're dealing with such
small particles they're moving with so
high velocities and their momentum is so
great that you need as big a region as
you can to increase the chances of
finding but not only finding them
determining precisely where they've come
from in order to work out exactly what
the collision was like
but i just want to show one thing brady
before we go and if we just look here i
didn't know about this if we look over
here we see this big thing that weighs
something like 100 tons
it's a door
and that door closes where those men are
it to seal in the
beam
and it's there to protect the beam it
protects it from the radiation and
particles that are coming shooting out
of the detector so as they don't then go
and destroy the beam that red thing up
there is a fire extinguisher there's a
group of them all along
the fire extinguishers once they're on
they take seven minutes to fill this
whole cavern with foam so as to protect
it safety is the most important thing
for the people here i couldn't envisage
it
being as big and and yet as compact you
i really feel what they mean by
compactors correct what do you mean you
just feel the density that's steel
that's solid steel all the way through
there these caps there's three layers in
there of these of these steel caps
we've got to go there's a crew from
russia here now it's it's amazing
there's non-stop
we're in the
sort of
the heart of the computing side of it
and the
where the data first comes in
and where you have to begin to make
decisions on what you're going to keep
and what you're not going to keep
and these are control
systems so if we just come down here for
example
these are the control systems that are
monitoring how the tracker is going in a
tracker is going
and then you've got we talked about the
triggering and how you make a decision
if we just go walk a lit back up here
slightly
you come to
the global trigger
and the global trigger is a is the
method that
decides starts deciding whether or not
to keep an event and to because there's
something like 800 million going on a
second they can't keep it all
and so they make these decisions on this
level one trigger and when they've
decided from the level one trigger
they're going to keep something they
they put it all together
at three and these are the cables in
which all it all comes through and you
can see where it's got the ecal and the
h cal
and the tracking
detectors and they
bring up that one event all together and
then they send it off to decide what to
do with it it's ridiculous because this
is just one little part of the whole
complex it's
i can't get my head around this it's so
big this is just crazy so we've got here
the just a set of the cables there's a
whole nother lot over over the other
side of this room
which have taken both the power down to
the detectors to to run them and then
they've got the i think it's these white
cables are the optical fibers where they
actually
transmit a lot of the data itself so
they've got a mixture here of the red
and blue which are the power cables and
then the white which are the optical
fibers
and just miles upon miles of them